a lifelong Democrat is telling it like
it is James Carville is tearing into
woke liberals who love to police
language and pronouns for ruining his
party I I find the left to be just
annoying the Western far left is
habitually the most stupid naive people
you can
imagine and they come up with these
really goofy constructs and it's all
about
feeling feeling feeling good about
yourself overeducated Coastal white
people got a hold to the word and if
they do everything else they completely
it up and pissed everybody in the
country off now now you're speaking my
life and if we just could get the
humanities faculty at Amherst to shut
the up would' be a lot better
off okay our overeducated Coastal white
people people uh you know Jesse the
truth is that you know he's speaking
really to Middle America he's saying the
Comm is on the east coast and the West
Coast are messing us up it's true what
would you rather be would you rather
have a lot of knowledge or would you
rather be a good decision maker I'd
rather be a good decision maker you
didn't have a choice
because all life is is a series of
decisions and all your life is is the
result of all of the decisions you've
ever made so you now have overeducated
Coastal Elite whites that are unhappy
because they've made bad decisions judge
they are living in small apartments with
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
student debt useless diplomas in bad
relationships poor eating habits poor
exercise habits and they are very upset
now when you are that upset because
you've made decisions based on
satisfying your immediate emotional
needs instead of long-term planing you
blame blame everybody else but yourself
and you blame society and what do you
want to do you want to tear down that
society and if you tear down Society
then everything will be better and what
happens you tear down society and you're
still unhappy they need to look inward
before they start wrecking everybody
else's life yeah but the problem is they
uh they have been doing that and it's
safe to say Carville and the Democrat
establishment are um you know that the
Carville in particular I should say has
been trying to explain to the Democrat
establishment that this has to stop this
whiny Progressive nonsense well you know
this is the man who helped Bill Clinton
win and what Jim Carville wants is to
win and what he's recognizing is that
they may be in danger of losing and
that's why he said wake the F up uh to
Democrats because he wants them to pay
attention to what's going on in
Philadelphia he wants them to pay
attention to the mistakes that have been
made and and you know in politics you
can win if you can recalibrate and
that's why Bill Clinton you know came up
with a welfare to work program he sensed
that the nation wanted to reign in
entitlements and he was willing to
answer to what the country wanted and it
is I love the part about feelings
because this is an we need to reverse
this um since the beginning of the Mi
generation we have turned more and more
Inward and it it is not about your
feelings it's about what's bigger than
you which is the country the future and
the way that you can contribute to it to
make it a better place and I think Jim
Carville recognizes that and I think
Bill Maher recognizes it as well he
wants to
win Greg I'm not up to embracing pumpkin
head just yet Carville is like a parent
who doesn't say anything about his
rotten brat until it affects him and
crashes his Mercedes this problem's been
here for years it's done Untold damage
it's caused a lot of death and now he
calls BS on it thanks but you're showing
up at last call let's not forget what
else he said he said that people that go
to Trump rallies are pretty much brain
dead deplorables said some pretty awful
things if he could call them he
would have so his criticisms actually
hit everyone and it doesn't come from a
place of common sense or common people
it comes from an elitist perch he's not
a man of the people he's a man
protecting the system that paid him well
on the whole he would prefer to jail a
trump supporter who stole a Podium over
an antia creep who burns a business so
there you go okay but he's wearing an
LSU Tiger shirt yeah got to give him
that Greg I don't give him anything you
don't give him anything okay well you
know what he's saying is that Biden
can't win with a woke agenda he actually
is just saying Biden can't win full stop
well we all think that but well we we
don't I'm in the separate bucket here
again is that a white liberal Coastal
Elite um but my life doesn't look like
what Jesse described um just putting it
out there um he said that any other
Democrat but Biden who's under 60 he
stipulated would get 55% of the vote and
that if we are heading towards having
multiple candidates in the race like a
No Labels candidate or a Joe mansion
that there is certainly no way that
Biden can win that and he was a strong
supporter of Joe Biden's in 2020 I want
to make that clear as well he said he
was the man for the job he doesn't feel
that that's the case anymore um there
are a lot of people that feel that way
it's it's certainly out in The Ether and
I thought it was really interesting
Matthew Aus um who's very Progressive he
founded box co-founded it with azra
Klein had um he has a substack called
slow boring and his post today was about
how Democrats need to stop with this
replacing the ticket and just focus on
winning and the way to win is to become
5 to 10% less Progressive than you are
in your policies you can keep the same
candidates but on things like no cash
bail for instance you see the S the
scene in Philadelphia you just say all
of you are going to jail and you're
staying in jail that's how we're going
to address this you can have a more Pro
police message you can talk about border
security there's going to be a
continuing resolution on border security
on border security Kirsten Cinema is
going to be part of that those are
things that Democrats can do without
betraying our core values and that would
allow the Biden Harris ticket to have a
much better shot at winning and it's
going to be close it's always going to
be close but I I thought that that was a
really interesting so pretend to be the
middle ground just like 2020 no it's not
pretending was that why just what
happened to this country pretended to be
moderate and look what happened look
what we got are you do you remember what
this country looked like when that
election happened yeah we had less crime
no you didn't actually all of the black
the black lives matter summer of looting
as you would call it happened under
President Trump that summer
wased and we were it was in Democrat
cities coming up hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else